[Music]
bleeding right now all right this eye is
beating in your face this story has a
really interesting twist that makes it
more surprising if i take this twist
away which i will do right now you're
gonna you won't even bat an eye okay so
hyundai was uh caught for using child
labor of course why they got plenty of
koreans who are a child korean kids
korean child
here's the twist
it's a hyundai subsidiary plant that's
located in alabama
oh we're using white people hell yeah
let's go how's it feel whitey
all the tables have turned
no time for little league i guess
yeah
that was that was really good i like
that he's the best it's super trippy
because like
doesn't that make it so weird that like
oh child labor in asia whatever dude
alabama my word
i'm one of our white children my word
that's a third world state though so
that's true that's true because they got
they got some states that are [ __ ] up
that's like cambodia prices be honest
with you this is the most woke thing
i've ever heard in my life
this is the most woke thing they had to
do in america oh you think that [ __ ]
asian people have sweatshops let me show
you alabama yeah boom whoa my people are
the best dude we have the highest
suicide rate in the world we're number
one in your face they beat japan huh we
beat japan japan's number two
[Laughter]
we'll get you back
oh yeah you underestimate
immediately goes back to japan to
campaign we need more suicides korea's
winning we gotta beat them out
yeah so it's uh kids as young as 12 like
these three kids were working there they
were all that's not that young that's
not that's just [ __ ] i want to see
some toddlers so here's the thing well
look at that that's education that is
dude that's that builds character i
thought i'd talk about like five years
old or eight years old we were taking
advantage of it was not bad that was
junior high this is like a metal
stamping plant do you know what it is
it's like it's like you know remember in
high school where kids had [ __ ] like
a metal shop and yeah yeah yeah what's
that it's that is that
hopefully they're getting paid so uh or
school credit i don't think you know how
uh child labor works they get paid they
usually don't
yeah they do oh they give him a [ __ ]
a can of tuna or some [ __ ] hey tuna's
good sardines
i don't know how you're gonna feel about
this the kids weren't white
what were they i think they were
guatemalan
[Music]
we're so [ __ ] up we're so funny we
never had little league on the calendar
let's go on this whole rant about white
kids no hey you gotta eat your pupusas
later [ __ ] this is wrong guatemala
guatemala's white adjacent man oh is it
i don't know why
hey i feel bad now that's [ __ ] up
i don't like this article man stop with
your [ __ ] twitch sorry
i'm upset guess what it was actually in
thailand
thailand
did they do a good job though i bet they
did a good job
uh it doesn't show their performance i
guess you can gauge that by hyundai's
share price or something
as a as a former child um worker
i personally yeah
i i i don't know why it's a bad thing
because i wanted so badly to be a part
of the child labor force you wanted to
did you
say you wanted to work as a kid when i
discovered money i was like oh [ __ ] so
you could like turn this in for whatever
i was like what do you guys have jobs i
want a [ __ ] job yup and then
everywhere i went they're like we ain't
hiring you you're like [ __ ] 10 years
old
yes so we made our own job where i went
i wanted to be in the child soldier
soldiers union oh where's that what
where at i don't know i just saw kids
with ak-47 that's pretty cool
child soldier seems pretty sweet what
was your guys first side hustle
uh i did a yard sale and then i would go
to costco and buy all the [ __ ] bold
candy and then sell it to all my at the
yard sale no no at school yeah yeah oh
wait what the yard you sold your parents
[ __ ] no no no i had my own toys oh okay
then i would sell it
to get new toys i don't know like seven
eight oh it's pretty good yeah seven for
your eyebrows like i gave you [ __ ]
she's like i don't know [ __ ]
simmering
[ __ ] east l.a is [ __ ] over here
dude who's asking for i don't give a
[ __ ] to gio's credits so many
bro she's probably waiting for you to
talk some [ __ ] no i've been biggie
bro corner cam look how tiny your hands
look on that thing that's crazy
shut up man there it is
i used to sell pizza to other kids
how old are you uh third grade fourth
grade because my parents used to admit
every every day for lunch they would
give me like a tony's pizza from the
oven so that came in eight slices
you had a whole pizza for every day
eight slices so i would sell them two
slices for a buck damn they sent you a
big ass that's a deal 50 cents a slice
i would just give hand jobs to my
t-shirts it's great
that's freezing
where did you make the money huh i got
eight pluses
he graduated hey he's looking at you
like
what an idiot dude what did you do with
that money hey mr johnson
is john cena yeah
john first commerce was kind of gay my
first like taste of commerce what was it
uh i sold mistletoe during christmas
that's not gay that's for boy scouts
that's really cute this is exactly how
i'm working as [ __ ] that's 10.
oh you guys do that you go to the woods
don't bring me into this your boys can
[ __ ] bring me into your [ __ ]
mistletoe fantasies right you go to the
woods and you [ __ ] pluck mistletoe
she used to blow weed in your guy's
mouth what are you talking about first
of all don't say your guys they're guys
multiple guys dude all the guys they're
they're men of honor
dudes of honor hey you want some weed
that's just look first of all you guys
don't know how to be economic okay
that's that's what it was we also don't
know how to be fruitful what was your
childhood my first hustle do you
remember um so there was a french class
at high school
french class the they would sell bon-bon
candies right did anybody remember these
candies
yeah yeah
well anyway so i would try and hustle
people to like get discounts if i bought
multiples from people and they would
eventually cut me deals and then i'll
just resell them in the next class
it was really dumb but it worked and i
would get like a buck like a buck 25
extra so i'll just buy chips with it you
were just hustling bulk deals for but
what is bulk at like a what i'll give
you a dollar if you give me three packs
it's like you're not gonna sell those by
fifth period you might as well just hook
me up do you guys remember in school you
[ __ ] get candy bars
to sell yeah i [ __ ] took it
home bro you suck so bad dude of course
you're talking about the seas toffee the
one with like caramel
i was so hungry twelve dollars a bar do
your parents have the pizza yeah my
parents got my mom beat the [ __ ] out of
me they ate half of them that's why they
stopped doing the candy bars and then
they just gave you the [ __ ] pamphlets
yeah this is the one with the briefcase
yeah because all the kids kept eating
them yeah when i when i got those
chocolate uh sales cards right on my way
home from school i just went door to
door and started [ __ ] selling it and
when i went home my mom was like
where did she get this money and i'm
like i sold it and she's like but how do
you know which house you went to and i
was like oh [ __ ] i don't know but they
bought it though this is the one that
they wanted oh [ __ ] so she had to take
me back like the route that i came from
and i didn't remember this was like
first grade sure that's so funny so she
had to go through every single door and
be like uh he he doesn't even know which
ones and they're like yeah we figured so
that's why we just gave him a couple
bucks because we thought it was cute
[ __ ] for first grade is what how old
are you six six or seven yeah because i
lived across the street from the school
so i was allowed to walk home you don't
grow up in the house do some dangerous
[ __ ] she's just walking around at six
dude but japanese kids are hella
resourceful do you know that [ __ ] my mom
didn't know that yes yeah think about
the show on netflix do this show yes she
let me walk around already when i was
like pretty young japanese people know
what to do they [ __ ] empower their
kids to allow them to do things that
they are capable of yeah but it works
only in japan luckily my mom didn't know
that we were in a
in a questionable neighborhood dude
compton is 100 okay
talking about it's totally fine it's all
good dude you're good my first uh side
hustle though is like i had i saved up
all this money from um allowance right
and then i went to our local pog card
shop oh [ __ ]
with the finger grooves as if it gave
you that much more traction yeah
everyone was in the park so i was like
all right i'ma finally get the big case
and sell the pogs nice so i got the pogs
and then i said but you know what i'm
gonna take out this business that i
bought the pogs from and sell it cheaper
than them
so you bought it from them expensive and
sold it cheaper dude i was like first
second grade you undercut the place you
bought from yes okay that was my idea
so i was like well he undercut
i must i'm gonna buy high and solo i'm
gonna buy this nothing's changed
origin that's my business partner guys
yeah
that's why
i bought the big box right that's our
boss and then the next day i [ __ ]
unloaded everything at school because it
was crazy it was like well you're gonna
sell it cheaper than the [ __ ] store
yeah because everyone went to that store
and i unloaded i was super excited
like how are you don't you do it joe
how'd you do it and at the time i just
thought a lot of money was like so sick
because i had pennies i had five sets i
had 25 i had one before i only had like
like a couple of rolls of dollars right
this felt like a lot ducktales
64 pennies today so i went to my dad and
i was like look at all this money i made
today and i told him the story and i
forgot so [ __ ] pissed at me because
he was trying to explain that you lost
money this is what profit is and i'm
like you stupid it's like that
you gave me one piece of paper yeah i
have 30 metal
literally
sounds like a good deal my dad's dumb
dude yeah
and he got [ __ ] pissed like trying to
explain to me what profit was and i was
smug as [ __ ] and i was like yeah but i'm
trying to beat this business yeah we
need to start smoking a cigar right now
i'm a businessman that's when you pick
up the penny you buy it you're like see
you take it's ten dollars you rip it
you're like
garbage
yeah put it in the rain see what happens
idiot
you